[Musique]
et exactement 19h14 ce soir qu'est ce
qu'il ya sur ces 8 il ya ghost musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
[Applaudissements]
stmicro attention on peut d'imane ben
oui attention au vert en plein test
bonjour talbot jeunes athlètes après
tout c'est lui que sexy donc il va
falloir répondre toujours de façon sexy
petite question quel est ce qui fait la
bise
ah non non
[Applaudissements]
allez bon ça c'est que ça fait tout mais
oui mais l'animal mais on n'a pas le
même sexy c'est tout non merci
c'est issa c'est ici justin tu viens
problème avec lui parce que quand tu
mates sexy pour l'action get you lie les
deux filles ont disséqué sous chirac et
les excès
[Musique]
il s'agit de naviguer sexo aînés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention s'est portée sur concours de
nouveau qualifié mois déjà vous vous
êtes dégueulasse ouais moi pierre d'un
et ça me donne neuf c'est donna summer 5
oui oui de la summer bien sûr que la
cousine d ophélie winter
[Applaudissements]
oui alors je fais pas que les jambes
edward c'est que cécile uhs i love ou si
vous êtes qualifiés pierobon aussi
bouger que c'est bon j'hésite entre
gilles et isabelle j'ai envie de voir
isabelle felici ça ne serait pas né ici
alors je l'attend encore jean-louis en
silence
toujours est ce que ça ne serait pas
choqué c'est la réponse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
les plats
[Musique]